on two three complete one more time
let's see let's say that lets say hi
guys this is autocomplete interview
nailed it I've watched a lot of these
videos I've been waiting for this moment
all my life I wasn't sure if this was
taper velcro
do the try guys smoke so people just
watching our videos being like those
guys seem like guys that yes hi a little
bit what do you think we love cigarettes
no we don't smoke cigarettes no one
smokes cigarettes no tobacco do the try
guys have a snapchat oh we should get on
that that's too much work we already
have so much we have to do do the try
guys win a Streamy we have won one
streaming we have it was fun on pictures
no mission because our show is true
we've only ones line but we are hosting
this year you know it's kind of like
come on Zach let's go let's do the try
guys that question one of us used to
smoke a lot of and then one of us smoke
say a regular healthy amount the other
part Ickx occasionally and the other to
barely partake but they will sometimes
regular healthy it's like having a glass
of wine when you go to bed right that's
regular healthy they say doctors say as
a group we support the legalization of
marijuana did the try guys break up how
do I wish there was a several month gap
where we had left our jobs at BuzzFeed
but hadn't actually told the world yet
and so we just didn't have videos pure
ironically at the time when everyone
thought we broke up
we were working more closely than ever
before yeah we are happy to say that we
did not break up we have a new channel
we're working and harder than ever
making more videos than ever and a lot
of great is coming more tries whoa Zach
are the try guy really friends are the
try guy I only know my gonna try got
really friends yeah we actually yeah we
are really friends yeah honestly we're
best friends yeah yeah it's weird
are the try guys Jewish Zach why don't
you take this one yes so we're all doing
well we're all do is yeah we're all do
it yeah how many Koreans oh I'm Jewish
are the trying guys still at BuzzFeed we
are not nope are the try guys
independent Wow yeah I'm just working
pretty codependent I would say yeah are
the try guys in LA yeah we were right
by a lot of the best bars in Louisiana
you can find them what yes we are in LA
we actually just opened up a new try
guys HQ office in Los Angeles I'm not
gonna get more specific than that
it is Ned's old house stuff no all right
the try guys straight all right
I've been approached with people on the
street who say oh my god I love the try
guys I love the LGBTQ representation
Zack and Keith are such a cute couple
and I'm like nah got it wrong right here
baby
but it shows what Smith and I are doing
a lot for representation you have a lot
for representation for straight dudes
who like love kissing up on each other
like we are the most like sensually like
comfortable straight dude group to ever
like brace the comedy scene we're very
comfortable with our sexuality but I'm
the only one who's had a dick in his
mouth
next board how old is Keith hammers
burger 38 no 37 no 31 yes what is Keith
hammers burger snap what is Keith
hammers burger snapchat probably at
Keith's ABS because everything is at
Keith's dad
I've not stepped chatted in a long time
uh-huh you won't find any content how
much is Keith Hopper's burger worth
probably at least like a couple hundred
pieces of fried chicken yeah I would say
a lot more than a cup I have time supply
fried chicken is how I would like to be
valued I am worth all the fried chicken
you could eat when is Keith Hopper's
burger getting married last September if
there's a video about it you can go
watch me get married where is Keith
harbor's burger what word is after where
is Keith hoppers birth yeah let's say
together one two three Carthage
Tennessee yep we're never gonna go no we
don't need to go there where does Keith
peppers Burger sleep come on sleep come
on sleep live oh man live in Los Angeles
not outside of LA just in the east side
was Keith hammers burger in 21 hi this
is Ray question there's a like
conspiracy theory that I was the bassist
in twenty one pilots because the bassist
looked kind of like me but an emo
version with long hair and left the band
and that wind up with like a couple
years before I started working at
BuzzFeed so people have created this
narrative that I was whoever that was
changed my name and started working as a
digital media producer you weren't a
really good man Keith why aren't you
proud of it yeah you guys made great
music together did I think you were
better together than they are now you
don't like them before they were twenty
one pilots when we were twenty two
pilots yeah who is Chen Liang Wow you
want to take this one Keith he is smart
he's handsome he loves animals he is
this one I just imagined that this is
you googling it yourself Eugene who is
you you're like trying to find out who
am i what movie is eugene from the tri
guys in I've recently started acting
again so I'm going to be in my first
indie feature called spring flower
I believe that comes out next year but
that's the public movie if you want to
see my home movies then you know I well
I thought about and I was like I don't
think I could do porn I don't have the
right temperament
I can't last long they're like marathon
runners it's impossible who could do
that I know that it's not possible
nobody could do that because they take
pills and they take breaks oh yeah and
they flippers so see Keith you could do
what nationality is eugene Liang ah
korean-american born in Texas parents
from Korea that's it is Eugene from tri
guys bye I've done most things and I've
been with a lot of variations of the
it's a complex question for the civil
answer which is sexy like sexy and we
should all just love each other right
right yeah sexy like sexy yeah I'm not
I'm not discerning
what is eating from the try guys family
secret gonna give you that I can't
answer that it's a family secret was
Eugene Liang it's so weird seeing my
name so many times I love so beautiful
was Eugene Liang I love so beautiful
what does that mean just answer the
question what's Eugene Liang a love so
beautiful I think the answer is no I'm
gonna say no I don't know what that is
when is Eugene Liang birthday I love
this grandma it's jr. 18th so I am a
Capricorn but right on the cusp of
Aquarius I'm also an Aries rising if
anyone wants to know and I believe my
moon is in Scorpio but at double check
Gemini Gemini Lea is Zack Kornfeld
single no it's a wired exclusive how
tall is that Kornfeld 5 2 4 9 I am 5 7
and 3/4 thank you very much how much do
you weigh though I'm pretty light I'm
like 135 yeah I'm a time I'm the tiny
okay I'm a tiny guy instead of big-boned
you're small bones yeah hey bird we're
all we're circling around the word frail
yeah
what is that Cornfeld snapchat you guys
gotta get over where is Zack Kornfeld
from Scarsdale New York the Julius town
oh how old is that Kornfeld
I am 28 years old mm-hmm he's the
youngest try guy I'm the baby yeah how
old is X from the try guys Wow
you guys gotta go girl more interesting
about me I was arrested once what for I
almost lost a testicle how'd that
happened I was on SNL who was the host
so many interesting things about me get
googling mad forward hey it's me did Ned
from try guys go to Yale I did I did go
to Yale it's the fact that I've recently
become proud of and most of my 20s I
said I went to school in can
at any time I said everyone's like yes
exactly what we did I believe that's
what time do I go that's what people
from you want how much is net foamer
worth you know I have a newborn baby
right now so whatever I was worth like a
couple of months ago is now where is Ned
foamer from I am friends with the Lord
over the Jacksonville Jaguars Wow
where does Ned former live I live in Los
Angeles they try to find you yeah they
want to come to my house two miles away
from me what is Ned Fullmer snapchat you
guys what breed is Ned Fullmer his dog
my dog is a labradoodle he's two and a
half years old he's chocolate he's not
made out of chocolate
well his color is brown but chocolates a
nice way of saying Brown who is ned
former actually know who is NetVault who
is why does he matter so how was that
I think the top question after this is
how do I unsubscribe from try guys we
love these videos and we've always
wanted to be in one so thanks for having
us wired